victory cigar time in the super dump
heizo delt hanging out with I saw Tyrann
Mathieu there last night long the LSU
guys back in town the championship won
by the LSU Tigers over the Clemson
Tigers Chris Sims was complaining
yesterday Peter because there's no
Tigers in either state well there are
LSU and Clemson and there's Joe burrow
with Odell Beckham jr. unless Beckham
gets traded to the Bengals he won't be
catching passes from Joe burrow this
year Brewer likely to be the number one
overall pick in the draft Peter I guess
the Bengals could screw this up you
covered them right out of the gates when
you got started in this business back in
the 80s do you think the Bengals will
screw this up absolutely not it's it's
impossible you know where John Harbaugh
said about his decision whether to play
guys or sit him and whether it was a
factor it's unanswerable well this is
it's impossible
that was a dumb segue it's absolutely
impossible to think that the Cincinnati
Bengals are not going to draft Joe
burrow and I'm gonna tell you the
biggest reason why as everybody has
tried to find holes in his game the
biggest reason why he absolutely
unequivocally will be the first pick in
the draft is this that is this little
statistic okay in in playing maybe five
or six of the three of the best five or
six teams in the country in the last
three games
Georgia Oklahoma Clemson he not only has
thrown 16 touchdowns and no
interceptions he not only is throwing
434 435 yards a game his yards per
attempt which is about the only easy
stat that NFL people love and view with
reverence is ten point four yards per
attempt
that means he's completing passes down
the field and it also means that in the
NFL were 8.0 is that really good yards
per attempt that means he walks into the
NFL and again you don't know what the
Bengals are gonna do with AJ Green but
assuming you've got a couple of really
good receivers AJ Green Tyler Boyd right
away and some developing receivers he's
gonna walk in there with guys he can
throw the ball to deep downfield and if
he is the first overall pick in the
draft Peter he will be the first number
one overall pick from LSU since do you
remember who do you remember who
JaMarcus Russell JaMarcus Russell in
2007 not that that should have any
impact wasn't you know what Mike Mike in
that particular case this was Al Davis
telling his team like Lane Kiffin I
think at the time right he's telling
Lane Kiffin
this is our guy we're gonna take him
Lane Kiffin didn't like JaMarcus Russell
and their scouts are saying oh my god
JaMarcus Russell he's got an incredible
arm but that's all he's got and they
picked them anyway yeah and they left on
the board Calvin Johnson that year the
team that relishes fast receivers could
have had one of the best receivers of
the generation fast tall big everything
great hands and they took JaMarcus
Russell instead but again that was a
long time ago different set of
circumstances
George Oboro fall more likely to come to
the NFL and make an impact then JaMarcus
Russell did and it's not Joe burrow to
the Bengals other teams will have an
opportunity at him there is the draft
order if you're watching on NBCSN
Bengals then Washington Lions Giants
dolphins Chargers Panthers Cardinals
Jaguars Browns round out the top ten
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports